elle attendait ce moment la présidente
du tribunal judiciaire de vesoul 52
travaux plus tard elles découvrent un
palais de justice
modernisée de fond en comble et surtout
a grandi visite des lieux commune avec
le procureur également l'un des acteurs
principaux de la juridiction et dès
l'entrée c'est un nouvel accueil qui
attend le public un espace plus
fonctionnel
un espace est dédié avec un box de
confidentialité qui permettra
effectivement des échanges privilégiés
sur une situation personnelle
depuis le 1er janvier on parle de
tribunal judiciaire alors pour
schématiser toute la justice de la haute
saône se retrouve à vesoul 700 m² en
toute surface et une centaine de
personnes y travailleront au quotidien
il a fallu pousser les murs et à grandir
dans l'ancienne cour avec l'aide des
entreprises audoises et pour le mobilier
l'initiative est à signaler et le
mobilier léger provient effectivement
des prisons de france puisqu'il a été
conçu réalisé par des détenus avec les
ambitions de l'institution judiciaire de
réinsertion sociale et appréhension des
récidives
le parcours des détenus a été revu il y
a des geôles tout est très sécurisé la
salle mythique des assises a repris de
sa splendeur en tout 20 magistrat qu'un
juge cinq procureurs 60 agents de greffe
et nouveauté une salle de crise qui peut
être verte par le procureur de la
république à tout moment ça peut être un
accident collectif imaginé un car
l'hiver avec plusieurs enfants blessés
ça peut être également bien sûr
malheureusement un attentat une prise
d'otage début de ce nouveau chapitre de
l'histoire du palais de justice de
vesoul lundi matin